didier guillaume le patron des sénateurs
socialistes est l'invité de preuves par
3 bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous donc pour ce rendez vous
hebdomadaire en direct comme chaque
mardi soir de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
rendez-vous au cours duquel bien vous
répondrez à trois grandes questions
premièrement qu'est ce qui cloche
les français et tous les baromètres
d'opinion à les sondages le montrent
sont sceptiques et critique vis-à-vis de
la politique qui est suivi alors est-ce
un manque de résultats économiques sans
doute également peut-être de couac au
sein du gouvernement vous répondre et
deuxièmement tout faire pour empêcher
une victoire du front national aux
élections régionales c'est ce qu'a dit
dimanche le premier ministre tout faire
mais quoi
eh bien vous le dirai à lucile malandain
de la sp enfin troisième question didier
guillaume quelle république demain
puisque vous avez lancé la réflexion au
sein même du groupe des sénateurs ps
pour une réforme institutionnelle donc
il ya beaucoup d'idées en ce moment qui
sont émis un peu de partout sur sur
l'avenir du du septennat du mandat
présidentiel sur le nombre de
parlementaires
eh bien vous ferez le point sur vos
réflexions tout à l'heure avec perrine
tarneaud mais d'abord l'actualité qui
est marquée par deux disparitions celle
d'helmut schmidt grand artisan bien sûr
de l'amitié franco-allemande qui
l'habite qu'il incarnait vraiment avec
sa relation privilégiée avec valéry
giscard d'estaing il fut aussi un grand
social démocrate
oui ces deux disparitions sont une drôle
de coïncidence alors là vous parlez
également leur parlons du philosophe oui
drôle de coïncidence parce que tous les
deux des gens qui ont parlé de l'europe
qui reprend les ballons le chancelier
allemand un grand européen
il a vraiment consolider l'amitié
franco-allemande avec valéry giscard
d'estaing le président giscard d'estaing
et il a travaillé beaucoup pour la
gauche et la social-démocratie en
allemagne l'esa a été pour nous enfin en
tout cas moi quand j'ai démarré la
politique
un exemple un exemple de la vision
européenne qui n'était pas évidente à
l'époque et que cet homme helmut schmidt
et réussi à faire ce qu'il a fait avec
la france quelques années seulement
après la seconde guerre mondiale ça fait
partie des grands européens et la paix
vous inspirer nombre les engagements
visionnaire oui parce que l'engagement
politique il part d'une chose c'est quoi
le monde et comment vivre en paix et
après la paix c'est la prospérité et
c'est vrai que pendant toutes ces années
nous étions en europe une période de
paix une période de grande prospérité
c'est un peu moins le cas aujourd'hui
pour la prospérité mais donc ces années
là ont été les belles années de de la
construction européenne de l' axe
franco-allemand du couple
franco-allemand savez giscard je voulais
dire que le couple franco-allemand à moi
belle allure aujourd'hui jusqu'à schmitt
mitterrand-kohl aujourd'hui hollande
merkel
c'est des moments différents c'est des
politiques différentes giscard et
schmitt n'avait pas la même orientation
politique comme mitterrand et comme
merkel et hollande aujourd'hui et en
même temps ce sont des chefs d'état des
chanceliers qui ont plus que tout une
idée de la nation une idée de l'europe
une idée de la construction européenne
et je pense que c'est vraiment oui c'est
c'est beaucoup à moi je ne peux pas me
résoudre à entendre sans cesse creed iv
c'est quand c'est un couple et ses
prises au jour le cas aujourd'hui quand
on regarde mais vous savez il ya des
coupes sion qui équilibré qui se
séparent et les coupes qui sont parfois
pas très équilibré qui vivent ensemble
très longtemps alors qu'on verra bien un
hameau sur andré glucksmann droids of de
toul et de tous les engagements qu'ils
avaient rompu d'ailleurs avec de manière
spectaculaire avec le marc lynn jusqu'à
s'éloigner d'ailleurs totalement de la
gauche
moi il m'a appris beaucoup duc manh
c'est lui qui a travaillé à ma
conscience politique c'est pour ça cette
coïncidence elle est l effort ni parce
que ces nouveaux philosophes cette
nouvelle philosophie
ces gens qui ont incarné quelque chose
michel grossiord quand on voit
aujourd'hui que les philosophes sont
rabougri sont des déclinistes sont des
gens qui ne parlent que du passé n'avons
parlé que la tendance avant la plupart
de ceux que l'on n'entend que l'on voit
dans les médias
wicked qui font la une de tous les
médias je trouve que c'est vraiment je
trouve que c'est vraiment dommage parce
que glucksmann avec ce qu'il a fait il
fit quelques routes avec ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment l'opposé
avant pour les autres on voulait se
reposer
oui je les oppose sur le fond de ce
qu'ils disent pas pas humainement je
n'ai rien agression sur le fond de ce
qu'ils disent glucksmann il a toujours
essayé de chercher d'éclairer d'ouvrir
la voie est de se tourner vers la droite
puisqu'il avait appelé à la sarkozy en
2007 il a fait un choix en 2000 serré
qui a pu nous surprendre il a choisi
nicolas sarkozy c'est sa responsabilité
mais vous savez il ya l'engagement
politique
mais moi ce que je retiens de luxe man
c'est tout ce qu'il a pu apporter à la
réflexion à la réflexion philosophique
aux femmes et aux hommes qui
s'intéressait au monde a les premières
questions concernant l'action
gouvernementale au kosovo maintenant
pourquoi ça cloche
pourquoi ça cloche par exemple votre
collègue opposant roger karoutchi certes
évoque lui un gouvernement à la dérive
vous voyez mais vous savez je pense que
à un moment où la france va pas si bien
que cela un moment où les français se
cherche et un moment nous sommes dans
une crise mondiale une crise européenne
crise française dont nous parlerons tout
à l'heure du front national oui mais
enfin dans ce contexte-là l'exigence
année en plus fort des gouvernants la
tache brune elle est sur toute l'europe
est aujourd'hui la responsabilité des
hommes et des femmes politiques
françaises française ceux qui aspirent
demain à gouverner à nouveau
c'est de la retenue de la hauteur de vue
et surtout d'avoir une autre idée de la
nationale quelles consignes pour les
gouvernants et les ministres par exemple
qui donne quand même trop souvent
reconnaissait le le spectacle décoiffant
par exemple nous ne parions pas de la
même chose mais là je vous parlais mais
vous parlez d'un gouvernement dit à la
dérive selon l'opposition ayant demandé
sur cette critique
ce gouvernement n'est pas à derry mais
vous savez aujourd'hui michel grossiord
tout est sur la table ce qui s'est passé
la semaine dernière nous aurions pu
l'éviter nous aurions les zigzags
aurions pu l'éviter mais le résultat moi
je l'applaudis dès demain a alors ce qui
compte est ce le résultat elles sont ce
qui compte c'est la façon d'y arriver
le sentiment de panique mais c'est pas
de la panique
c'est simplement peut-être un manque de
vision de certains sujets sûr si on les
reprend assez rapidement sur la demi
part pour moi
d'accord parce que vous me parlez de
quoi que vous ne voulez pas qu'on a eu
du mal a dit mais il n'y a pas de
revirement
d'accord je voulais vous parler par
exemple aujourd'hui même oui un dernier
exemple aux incohérences
oui l'assouplissement de la loi evin
pour la mobilité sur le club parce que
c'est de là que parce que d'un côté vous
avez la ministre de la santé mary
touraine qui dit toucher à ce texte
porterait un grave préjudice à l'enquêté
publique et de l'autre vous allez
emmanuel macron qu'ils n'ont pas du tout
pas du tout il n'y a aucune
contradiction avec les objectifs de
santé publique aucune contradiction
aucune aucune je vais prendre deux ou
trois exemples
mais ce sujet que vous évoquez sur
l'assouplissement de la loi evin qui
n'est pas de l'assouplissement de la loi
evin ce nom nous parlons parce que
personne ne regarde au fond du sujet
c'est simplement après la condamnation
d'un magazine qui est fait de la
publicité pour une boisson effervescente
du nord de la france
nous souhaitons que pour ce qui concerne
le no tourisme les caf paix publique les
caves collective ou particulière pour on
veut accueillir ans va être le premier
pays touristique en france dans les 88
millions de personnes qu'est ce qu'ils
viennent faire en france la culture
l'histoire le patrimoine mais la
gastronomie et le vin
oui et alors moi je veux que nous
puissions continuer à faire cela le
débat est déjà dans l'est c'est pour ça
qu'il faut c'est elle la spéciale de la
santé marisol touraine et la recherche
mais marie sur le tour il dit c'est un
coup porté à l'assemblée
je ne partage pas cet avis à j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour marisol
touraine qui est une grande ministre de
la santé
mais ici au sénat les sénateurs
socialistes et républicains ont voté
l'amendement qui avait été préparé par
le gouvernement dans le cadre de la loi
macron numéro un pour permettre cet
assouplissement simplement s'il conseil
constitutionnel ne l'avait pas invalidé
avec la loi macro nous n'en parlerions
plus aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que m le
vin dans la loi santé pour la ministre
en charge de ce domaine
ça peut lui poser un problème mais moi
j'affirme ici à votre antenne à public
sénat trompa preuve par trois qu'il n'y
a aucun problème je vais les jeunes qui
roulent trop vite qu'un accident qui
parfois dramatiquement se tuent ils ont
pas bu du bordeaux du bourgogne
du 26 mois du saint joseph du
crozes-hermitage ou de l'ermitage ils
ont bu des boissons très forte
ils ont bu des remixes ils mélangent
savait exactement avec des logements du
dos il faudrait favoriser les pas du
tout mais s'ils font mais ce n'est pas
vrai à ce texte moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé avec ses fans le foll dans le
cadre de la loi
mc ren ce texte permet simplement
juridiquement de sécuriser les caves de
sécuriser les ceux qui vendent du vin
pour touristes qui en parle notamment
dans les médias exactement là où les
médias alors la polémique va pas encore
retombée non mais mais vous savez
aujourd'hui tout est sur la table
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure twitter je
vois des dépêches etc tout est sur la
table c'est heureux ben c'est très bien
mais on peut pas dire que lorsqu'il y
ait un débat c'est un couac
et puis dire lorsque circuit il ya des c
c'est tout ça est cadenassée bon alors
restons avec emmanuel macron mais est ce
que c'est un aiguillon utile aujourd'hui
très utile à qui à quoi
c'était très utile de la gauche très
utile pour faire avancer la société
je pense que emmanuel macron fait partie
de ces jeunes personnes jeunes hommes en
politique qui font du bien qui régénère
qui aère à gauche on a besoin à la
gauche on a besoin et j'espère et je lui
lance un appel à ce soir de preuves par
3 chez vous je lui demande de se
présenter aux élections législatives je
pense que emmanuel macron il faut qu'il
puisse poursuivre son chemin aujourd'hui
a eu un parcours qui est passé
directement de la haute fonction
publique de l'elysée au gouvernement il
n'a eu d'autre et tous ceux mis à part
emmanuel macron je veux pas les citer
parce que ça peut leur faire de la peine
qui est qu'on a appelée de la société
civile qui sont retrouvés au
gouvernement ils ont tous ce soir et
dont tous raté donc éventuellement il
faut qu'ils la bouclier électoral et à
bouclier non pas du tout emmanuel macron
réussi mais je pense que en politique la
plus belle des récompenses
la plus belle chose que l'on peut avoir
c'est la majorité de ses congénères
mâles assez paradoxale quand même nom
aura si bien que la vois je
je lui demande souvent dit l'idée
moderne mais nuit il a dit le cursus des
politiques classiques ça ne m'intéresse
pas l'élection c'est là peut-être ni
ratifié ben non mais oui il a bien tenu
des propos qui ont choqué beaucoup
d'élus wii noire vous peut-être doivent
alors passer non mais tout dépend ce que
faire emmanuel macron mais c'est pas le
juger a dit mais s'ils considèrent
qu'être élu c'est quelque chose de
suranné et qu'il ne faut pas le faire
emmanuel macron dans les mois qui
viennent arrêtera la politique on peut
pas être en politique dans les années
même dans les décennies qui me manque
pas du tout anodin poursuit emmanuel
macron n'est pas député en 2017 il
pourra pas continuer à faire de la
politique faire comment quand vous
interrogez les gens sur votre plateau
caisses qui sont ils
ce sont des élus dilue de la république
là c'est plus qu'une invitation donc je
prends une injonction pour lui s'il
souray cités ci-dessus et éthiques
s'il souhaite faire de la politique à et
moi je l'appelle de mes voeux ce qu'il
fasse de la politique alors je pense
qu'il devra passer par le suffrage
universel
mais comme tout le monde c'est bien
normal on lui a trouvé ça y est la
circonscription et revenant mais ça
c'est votre sujet énormément mais une
circonscription sont emmenés par les
départs autorisés ne souhaite pas il
n'était pas un jeu de dominos ne trouve
pas les circonscriptions
oui bien sûr pas commettre loto
aujourd'hui à louis ii pour le ps c'est
assez dur mais c'est dur pour tout
particulièrement en plomb là par contre
les électeurs ne sont pas des boeufs nés
et ne sont pas des pions vous voulez
avait proposé directement me l'avait dit
la proposition incitations il connaît ma
position vous en parlait déjà il connaît
ma position est la sienne
qu'est ce que c'est là que rien alors on
va éviter aux vagues été sa réponse à
cette proposition que vous lui faites ce
soir sur le plateau de preuves par 3 on
va l'écouter parce que cette dernière
l'idée elle fait fulminer une partie de
la gauche de la gauche du ps
c'est-à-dire accroître la part du mérite
dans la rémunération des fonctionnaires
je pense qu'il faut accroître la part en
effet de mérite
la part d'évaluation dans la
rémunération à soupe lui c'est une façon
de le moderniser parce que qu'est-ce qui
justifie ensuite qu' on puisse être
protégé en quelque sorte de toutes les
variations d'une forme de deux
performances simplement la performance
quand on est fonctionnaire
elle ne se mesure pas forcément comme
dans l'autre la seconde est en jeu
ray général vous êtes alors vous êtes
d'accord avec lui soit vous êtes aussi
d'accord sur la réforme du statut des
fonctionnaires oui attendait ça existe
déjà tout cela s'est passé voilà mais
aujourd'hui non mason qui m'a toujours
poussé le curseur plus loin mais il est
là pour çà a aujourd'hui il ya deux
solutions soit on fait du surplace et
c'est comme en vélo si on arrête de
pédaler on tombe et on n'est pas loin de
tomber si on n'accélère pas là parce que
ça ne va pas assez vite soit on trial
est en avance et emmanuel macron veut
pédaler après ne ne prenons pas
l'interview d'europe 1 ce matin et en le
décortiquant disant ça y est il veut
taper les fonctionnaires ça suffit il
faut pas non plus tomber dans la chasse
à la chasse aux maquereaux on n'est pas
ouverte la chasse aux maquereaux à moi
je défendrai java vous dit toujours et
dire les quelque chose d'intéressant à
dire que ça ne va pas assez vite
mais aussi paradoxal de dire ça quand on
préside le groupe socialiste au sénat
puisque regarder les dernières
propositions de réformes qui ont été
avancées par le gouvernement la réforme
du code du travail la réforme du
finances des finances des collectivités
locales hop c'est pour 2018 ou alors
tout vraiment juste maintenant c'est
votre interprète si dans votre
interprétation de faire regarder la
ville disent regardez les réformes qui
ont été lancées par ce gouvernement
jamais un gouvernement n'a jamais lancé
l'otan sur la baisse des déficits sur la
réforme la loi macro sur la justice mans
vient de voter mais encore assez vite
vous avez aimé parce qu'il faut
continuer sans cesse ça ne va pas assez
vite parce qu'il ne faut pas s'arrêter
certains voudraient que nous soyons dans
l'immobilisme il ya une gauche archaïque
et une gauche moderne
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le dogmatisme
n'a plus lieu d'être d'accord moi je
respecte toutes les pensées la gauche et
j'appelle tous mes camarades de gauche
tous mes amis de gauche qu'ils soient
communistes écologistes socialistes
radicaux à avancer ensemble dans
l'intérêt général dans la gloire moder à
ce que ce qu'il ya une chose dont je
suis sûr c'est que si en 2017
la droite prenez le pouvoir alors là
nous verrions non pas des faibles
avancées mais des grands reculs la
déstructuration du marché du travail on
connaît leur programme maintenant donc
avançons et sur les fonctionnaires c'est
pas à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
nous verrons bien que les imams et
pourquoi pas vous me posez la question
je vais très bien
la gauche moderne et celle qu'incarne
emmanuel mac mais il faut faire
attention parce qu'il n'ya pas la gauche
mais oui mais moi j'ai au dernier donc
ma chère parce que nous avons besoin
d'une gauche moderne veut dire libera ce
cas une gauche dogmatique libera nord la
guerre moderne
la gauche moderne d'une gauche
réformiste c'est le social réformisme
c'est pas le nave réalisme assurément
pas le premier libéralisme c'est la
dérégulation
moi je suis content là des règles
assurant voit où cela nous a mené de
questions encore avant de parler du
front national ouais sur les impôts
est ce que vous êtes ceux favorables la
baisse de la csg qui est proposée par
jean marc ayrault qui fédère
manifestement pas mal de députés
derrière lui et qui prône parallèlement
un impôt citoyen pour tous
la première phrase de ma réponse venait
me dire c'est la langue de bois je
n'aime pas dans leurs roues à la saute
alors je le dis je ne peux pas répondre
à cette question pourquoi et puis je
vous expliquais en une minute trente
c'est très important ce sujet j'ai
contribué à écrire dans le programme du
ps à réfléchir pour la campagne
présidentielle qu'il fallait essayer de
fusionner l'impôt sur le revenu et la
csg
donc je fais une promesse je suis je
suis clair là dessus sauf que il y a eu
un nouveau paradigme paradigme pardon à
partir du moment où l'on dit qu'il n'ya
plus de hausse d'impôt ah oui et que
nous allons les réduire oui alors je
suis favorable a regroupé je suis
favorable à l'impôt à la source je suis
favorable à une évolution à condition
que la conséquence soit qu'il y ait zéro
augmentation d'impôts et si embassies
élargir et à dreux là si on perd ce sera
le matraquage des classements il est bas
alors je suis opposé l'homme vous êtes
au poids je suis au pouvoir allier
opposition à la position des
républicains qui disent ça mais dont je
me rallie à la position du premier
ministre et du président de l'aje la
météo si clair dans le relais à
propositions des sirènes et c'est
seulement matignon non mais on s'est
excusé moi d'insister parce que nous
allons vite et pour tout les spectateurs
comprennent bien on ne peut pas dire je
suis pour ou contre un aujourd'hui le
problème de la prime
la prime d'actualité la prime pour
l'emploi qui est basé sur les revenus de
l'année d'avant si on pouvait le régler
par la baisse de la csg pour les plus
faibles revenus
j'y serai favorable je ne suis pas
favorable à l'augmentation de la csg
pour les classes moyennes et bien
poindre les glaces fait perdre un oeil
les réformes classes moyennes sont les
vaches à lait du système fiscal depuis
des années et je pense qu'aujourd'hui ça
suffit voilà qui est clair voilà suffit
concernant le faire le président a
répliqué le premier ministre maintenant
dont l'amendement présenté par jean marc
ayrault pour qui j'ai le plus grand
respect il ya des choses intéressantes
qu'il faut regarder l'impôt citoyen et
qui n'est pas dans la durée dans la
durée dans la durée alors vous savez nos
concitoyens veulent pas exact fiscale
d'accord deuxième grande partie de
l'émission maintenant des visionnaires
avec la deuxième question on a entendu
manuel valls ce week-end martelé il faut
tout faire pour qu'il n'y ait pas des
victoires du front national aux
élections régionales le fn il est en
tête dans au premier tour dans quatre
régions on l'a vu juste en laissant
travailler sur wii alors tout faire ça
veut dire quoi mais là je vais je
excusez moi d'être point qu'ils
voulaient poser avec le front national
n'est pas en tête dans quatre régions
selon les sondages voilà voilà donc au
premier tour à la pour l'instant on va
rire que les sondages se trompent faire
barrage
mais ça veut dire quoi commencer ce que
va vous demandez lui si malanda de la
sbm alors on va d'abord écouté le
premier ministre qui parle d'un drame
oui ça sonne bien sûr que c'est un drame
que le front national gagne une deux ou
trois régions pour d'abord les habitants
de ces régions conviction c'est que le
front national n'est même pas la france
donc quand vous le dira toujours que le
front national chez c'est souligner son
très dur pour les petits pour les
retraités pour les jeunes pour les
précaires pour les politiques publiques
mais pour l'éducation est ce que vous la
culture vous avez entendu
manuel valls parlé de drame c'est une
région passé au front national se
souviendra donc vous êtes d'accord pour
fait cette idée de dramatiser les choses
à nouveau des stratégies ne s'agit pas
de stratégie si le front national gagne
région c'est un drame pour la république
tel drame pour nous
française mais plus que tout c'est un
grand pour les citoyens qui vivront
c'est un drame pour la république parce
que quelle image donnerions-nous à
l'extérieur enfin le front national est
un parti qui se présente aux élections
mais ce n'est pas un parti comme comme
comme une autre que dites vous alors aux
électeurs du front national puisque non
mais moi je m'adresserai majorité des
gens vous allez dire c'est encore un
sondage et 52% des français n'en ferait
pas un drame
oui mais nous avons besoin d'éclairer
les français dans les quatre semaines
qui nous approchent du premier tour sur
ce que serait et ce qu'est le programme
des heures et des autres parce qu'une
élection s'est pas un casting c'est pas
qui est le plus beau la femme l'homme
etc
c'est pas là le brushing ou la cravate
sait quel est le programme
la gauche les socialistes on entend la
droite en ahl front national à ce ne
sont pas les mêmes mais je me sens plus
proche de la droite que du front
national et donc qu'amd il faut tout
faire pour empêcher que le front
national gagne une région il va falloir
convaincre les électeurs
un à un que ce serait un drame ce serait
surtout dramatique pour eux prenons
quelques exemples quand cet après midi
encore madame le pen prend les mêmes
phrases les mêmes que son que son père
qui montrait les sidaïques et qui elle
dit il faut lutter contre les épidémies
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça mais les
hommes c'est louis lê huu et l'égalité
elle veut elle dit elle dit elle a écrit
elle veut éradiquer mais il assure une
contamination bactérienne lutter contre
la présence alarmante de maladies
contagieuses non-européenne et vous vous
rendez compte alors faire coiffer ses
excès du dic tous fermés faire faire
quoi convaincre
comment réagissez vous à cette
expression là nous
déjà je suis un acteur et intérêts
offusquer mais moi j'ai toujours
considéré que marine le pen à paarl
ripolinage de son père c'est la même
chose
elle tient les mêmes disent que vous
avez que le fn après qu alors que ce
programme était publié par la voix
d'hervé le fn plaide lapsus
ouais enfin bon ça va à quoi parce que
c'est toujours dans la puce mais il
parle un stand de gens aux gens qu'ils
sont racistes aux gens qui sont
homophobes et nous ne luttons contre le
racisme nous luttons contre le contre
l'homophobie
donc pour répondre à votre question il
est encore temps bien sûr qu'il est
temps
dans quatre semaines pour que les listes
des socialistes et de leur rassemblement
les radicaux ici ou là les écologistes
et autres puissent être le plus haut
possible
nous devons faire le match et pour faire
ce match il faut que la gauche soit le
plus haut possible au premier tour je
regrette
nous l'avons déjà dit que la grosse la
gauche ne soit pas razon a grossi
pourquoi s'interroge sur la gauche en
sauver un petit peu sur la gauche parce
que à gauche
vous n'êtes pas tous d'accord
le parti de gauche le front de gauche le
pc les verts critiquent beaucoup le
gouvernement met sur l'a26 des choses
même très virulente très contrôlée mais
nous valions des régionales dans
lesquelles il son vice-président dans
lesquelles les gens voter sans la
campagne des régionales en plus bien sûr
mais tour alors comment ça va au soir du
premier tour
je pense que ceux qui ont géré les
régions pendant des années 6 en 12 ans
ou 18 ans qui ont pris des chemins
différents que je regrette notamment
dans deux régions nord pas de calais
picardie et paca où là il ya un vrai
risque extrême droite que ces gens là se
disent bon nous critiquons du
gouvernement c'est une chose mais
lorsqu'il s'agit de l'intérêt de la
région
nous pensons que pierre de saintignon
sera un bien meilleur président que
xavier bertrand
nous pensons que que jean-jack queyranne
sera un bien meilleur président que
monsieur wauquiez et donc nous nous
rassemblons derrière le programme commun
que nous pouvons avoir nous avons géré
les régions toutes les délibérations à
l'unanimité nous avons transformé les
lycées nous avons travaillé sur
l'agriculture nous avons travaillé sur
l'économie sur les clusters nous avons
dynamiser et alors on s'arrêterait parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord avec la
politique économique de monsieur untel
de notions un tel nom alors ça c'est
votre démonstration on vient on l'a
entendu oui mais alors il ya quinze
jours sur ce plateau
il y avait jean luc mélenchon aurait lui
il entend pas du tout les choses non non
sont là il al'impression là en vous
entendant là ne vous lui mettez écoutez
bien le revolver sur la tempe et il vous
renvoie à votre refus de vous désister
en sa faveur
ses troupes aux municipales à grenoble
on écoute jean luc mélenchon mais de
quel droit au nom du fait que ça n'est
pas la même chose
ils vont avoir le droit de venir à me
mettre le revolver sur la tempe me dire
vote pour nous d fêté liste et vient
vite avec nous de peur du front national
si on fait ça le front national sera
sans doute plus puissants pourquoi parce
que les gens diront la seule manière
qu'on a deux fils tout ce bazar par
terre c'est de voter pour eux moi je ne
m'adresse pas jean-luc mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon à l'extrême gauche
emploient parfois les mêmes arguments
que ceux de l'extrême droite pas sur les
valeurs pas sur le et cetera mais sûr il
faut tout le monde en
l'air le coup de balai et c'est
inacceptable
moi je m'adresse pas jeu
donc ces convois y aura aucun problème
au sein du premier tour jeudi j'espère
que europe écologie les verts le parti
communiste français que tous les autres
à gauche se rassemble dans l'intérêt des
françaises et des français
dans les régions c'est sask dont il
s'agit à la prospérité ni gaz ou le
total des voix de gauche tant que vous
voulez additionner est inférieure au
total des voix des républicains donnent
au coude va nous prendre nous prendrons
nos responsabilités nous le dira non
faut pas le voir comment ça parce que
parce que quand vous allez un match de
rugby vous savez pas quel qui va gagner
dans se rendre aux responsabilités faut
nous dire avait dans les appellera au
front républicain vous pouvez le dire
non parce que dans le derby basque le
week-end dernier bayonne contre biarritz
bayonne gagner largement à la mi temps
et bien avancer la médecine je vais vous
dire il faut savoir le résultat du 6
décembre au soir
nous avons totalisé les voix de gauche
les voix de droite si les voix de gauche
que vous envisagez par exemple de voter
pour monsieur estrosi s'écouter mois ci
les voix de gauche ça ne marche pas
comme cela
après tout les wolves est obligé de vous
représenter cette possibilité vous avez
le droit de me poser les questions que
vous voulez mais j'ai le droit de
répondre comme je veux répondre et je
vous dis très amicale de cuir les
questionnements et je vais vous
expliquer
nous allons regarder les totaux si le
total des voix de gauche est supérieur
au total des voix de droite
ça sera à monsieur xavier bertrand de
prendre ses responsabilités d'accord et
par rapport à ce qu'a dit le premier j'y
viens
par rapport à ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre si le total des voix de gauche
est inférieur total des voix de droite
nous prendrons nos responsabilités pour
empêcher que marine le pen ici où notre
ailleurs nous verrons bien mais je
voudrais simplement vous dire une chose
aux élections législatives du doubs il y
a un an lorsqu'il y avait monsieur
barbier socialiste face au front
national
nicolas sarkozy n'a pas voulu choisir
parce que je pense que nicolas sarkozy
ne veut pas choisir entre l'extrême
droite et les socialistes elle nous ne
sommes jamais trompé une seule fois
nicolas sarkozy le chef de l'opposition
oui le chef du principal des auditions
les républicains
même manuel valls a dit dimanche que
apparemment il estimait qu'il ne se
situait plus du côté la république
puisqu'il ne respectait pas l'état de
droit il l'a pas dit comme ça ils
prenaient une phrase et ils prennent une
phrase je pense et il attaque il a sorti
une opposition qu'on a juste oui et bien
sûr nicolas sarkozy de l'état de droit
il l'a dit nicolas sarkozy a été
président de la république chef de
l'état
aujourd'hui il agit comme un chacun un
chef du clan ben c'est pas la hauteur
des l'opposition oui mais pas d'un clan
et aujourd'hui les positions d'extrême
droite isation qu'il fait prendre à
l'ump rebaptisée les républicains sont
terribles quand il parle de fuite d'eau
comparant les immigrés à des fuites
d'eau dans une cuisine mais vous vous
rendez compte que c'est vous rendez
compte la personne qui entend qui reçoit
ce ce message ce message là ce n'est pas
acceptable
donc moi j'appelle au party les
républicains à de la retenue nous en
parlons clair en début d'émission à de
la hauteur et tu dis l'enjeu c'est la
france et on ne peut pas se ficher de la
france uniquement pour des résultats
électoraux qui pourrait être le
piédestal pour la primaire et pour la
prochaine présidentielle vous avez aussi
des mots très durs pour nicolas sarkozy
vous parlez de son extrême droitisation
vous allez donc être choqués demain 11
novembre de le voir invité par france
bien sûr je verrai monnaies du 11
novembre ça ça c'est une haute idée de
la république nicolas sarkozy a été chef
de l'état il est invité en tant que tel
en tant qu'ancien président de la
république aux côtés de l'actuel le 11
novembre pascal or si le 11 novembre la
nation française ne peut pas se
rassembler la france est foutue alors
nicolas sarkozy multiplie par ailleurs
les attaques contre le manque d'autorité
de l'état
oui on l'écouté vous allez mourir là
également répondre c'est ça la france
d'aujourd'hui
ce deux poids et deux mesures on peut
bloquer une autoroute sans rien dire on
peut s'opposer une perquisition en des
rires on peut lyncher un cas de défense
on dit rien ma revanche l'avocat le
veilleur
et que dire de celui qui en rêve avait
pensé protester contre la venue de
monsieur hollande dans sa région et qui
fut mis en garde à vue avant de procéder
à la moindre menace puisqu'on a été le
chercher avant même que son excellence
le président de la république et met les
pieds dans cette région
imaginez que nous ayons fait ça mais il
a fait bien pire nicolas sarkozy mais il
est amnésique il ment ou tout simplement
ils le gagnent galvaniser ses troupes
mais quand pendant trois semaines la
france est à feu et à sang qu'à clichy
ça brûle qu'il ya des morts
qu'est ce qui l'a fait nicolas sarkozy
planqué au château de l'elysée akkaya en
étant totalement pétrifié et les
socialistes à l'époque ont eu la
responsabilité n'ont jamais dit un mot
de plus puisque quand la france est mise
à mal
alors il faut avoir de la hauteur de vue
nicolas sarkozy n'en a pas et lorsqu'il
dit chercher une autorité ou et
l'autorité de l'état alors selon des ong
je vais vous répondre
nicolas sarkozy confond autoritarisme et
autorités pour nicolas sarkozy si je
suis le patron écrasé vous tous vous
n'avez pas le droit de désigner vos
candidats fait ce que j'ai envie de dire
mais je ce que je constate aujourd'hui
c'est que il parle de l'autorité de
l'état
mais j'ai l'impression qu'il a peu
d'autorité dans son parti il ya qu'à
voir ce qui s'est passé samedi au
conseil national les principaux
dirigeants n'étaient pas là il n'arrive
pas à imposer ses vues et on verra ce
qui se passera à la primaube qu'on a
l'impression que vous avez comme je ne
rêve pas vous avez tous vos arguments
rôdés mais c'est pas des arguments
c'est l'idée que nous faisons de la
france et de la politique et ma
grand-mère me disait toujours il faut
toujours balayer devant sa porte
je pense que nicolas sarkozy devrait
balayer devant sa porte avant de faire
diversion parce que c'est de la
diversion mais il l'a fait avec des mots
tellement fort tout le premier ministre
a qualifié leur télé france mêlée alors
exemple et bien sûr de violence je peux
vous en attendant lisez peux vous en
citer d'autres
sur le total avant mais bien sûr et où
il y avait jamais d'interpellations vous
un citoyen jamais d'interpeller le
discours le discours de nicolas sarkozy
à grenoble en 2010 où le discours de
latran
c'est des discours qui ne sont pas
acceptables en république
et lorsque ses conseillers monsieur
buisson monsieur guaino et c'est lui
font faire cela ils le font dériver
il veut être lui l'aspirateur à voix du
front national
ce que vous dit je pense qu'il risque de
prendre le ventilateur en pleine figure
dit c'est que si le front national
remportait une région se serait tu as
bram
oui et donc si nicolas sarkozy ou son
parti remportait une région ce serait
pas un drame également finalement ben où
ont pris place sur la gauche qu'il
importe évidemment mais nous ne faisons
jamais normal bonne méthode
tout le monde tout le monde est un drame
souffre non j'ai pas dit ça
non j'ai pas du tout dit ça j'ai dit que
si le front national remporter une
région ce serait un drame si c'est les
républicains qui rapporte des régions et
alors tu vous faire un scoop
ils vont remporter nous n'avons mettez
une sur 22 je pense pas qu'en face le
grand chelem
donc ils vont à remporter et ça
s'appelle l'alternance démocratique
ce que je regrette simplement c'est les
dérives verbales voire idéologique que
nicolas sarkozy fait prendre à son parti
elles sont très gras mais j'ai
l'impression que ça ne marche pas si
bien que cela qu'un revenons justement
sur sur la question des régionales est
ce que est ce que selon vous il est
possible que la gauche qu'elle remporte
certaines régions combien je l'espère
les plus importantes la moitié comment
est ce que vous vous je l'espère je
l'espère j'espère que j'espère que jean
yves le drian bretagne alain rousset en
aquitaine carole delga en midi-pyrénées
languedoc-roussillon claude bartolone en
ile de france
jean-jack queyranne a atteint 20 en
rhône alpes auvergne pourquoi pas et
puis vous savez la corse et à la guyane
on parle jamais des ultramarins la gale
la guadeloupe la réunion enfin voila moi
ce nous ce que nous faisons ce que nous
voulons c'est pas tout gagné par vous
dire moi je vais vous dire aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui et qu'elle
combien ou ne pas utiliser la langue de
bois nous avons nous gérons trop de
régions à voir mais enfin ça ça se
saurait si la gauche avait la marche des
dames est une région semaine de mon a
bénéficié pendant les mandats de la
droite du vent
qui nous étaient favorables parce que
chaque fois qu'il était chaque fois
qu'il ya des zéniths région est là mais
parce que nous avons bénéficié d'un vent
dans le dos terrible on nous avions des
belles liste des beaux programmes parce
que nous avions des programmes et puis
nous étions de gauche et nous gagnons
les élections
aujourd'hui le vent dans le dos c'est la
droite qui l'a et nous on veut c'est de
faire mentir cela c'est de faire en
sorte que à contrevent le vent n'emmener
nous sommes capables d'avancer c'est ce
que nous on essaie de faire donc nous
voulons gagner le plus de régions
possible mais moi je ne fais pas de
pronostics je suis pas madame irma comme
disaient les nos anciens on verra bien
nous faisons tout aussi bleu que la
droite ne fasse pas grand chelem mais je
peux vous dire ce soir que la droite ne
fera pas le grand chelem et que la
droite peut même être surprise de elle
s'inquiète elle s'inquiétait
l'impression une question est l'un des
légumes sur l'abandon récent du vote des
étrangers aux élections locales
on oublie ce totem de la gauche en c'est
le mot qui a été utilisé par manuel
valls était lundi la semaine dernière
pourtant vous souvenez bien ici un déçu
quand même à votre grande fierté du
sénat de gauche en décembre 2011
peut-être que vous allez vous
reconnaitre forcément vous allez me
reconnaître dans les propos tenus à
l'époque par jean pierre sueur il était
un devoir moral pour nous par rapport à
cet engagement moral que d'inscrire ce
texte nous le faisons en vertu des
principes des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres alors l'engagement moral et
principes moraux tout ça est foulée aux
pieds aujourd'hui pas du tout pas du
tout nous avons toujours été favorables
à aux élections aux élections locales du
vote des étrangers propositions de
françois mitterrand en 1981 un promesse
de françois hollande promesses de
françois hollande de ségolène royal et
de la gauche du sellier sociaux et nous
l'avons vu aujourd'hui on dit non c'est
un totem on n'en parle plus des noms
vous faites une mauvaise appréciation
vous avez fait une peut-être une
nouvelle analyse michel grossiord
pourquoi nous disons cela parce que nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de le mettre
en place est pas tout à fait de six
premiers mois je vous le dis et nous
n'avons pas d'avion civil
il parle de jeu
je vais finir je vais finalement de la
majorité d'être juré cas je vais je vais
finir je vous parlais tout à l'heure du
pragmatisme face au dogmatisme et moi
j'assume les choses c'est moi je dis les
choses très clairement comme je les
pense sans arrière pensée et sans qu'on
me dicte ce que je dois à dire nous ne
sommes pas à même de le faire voter si
nous pouvions le fait n'est aujourd'hui
dj serait très favorable mais nous
pouvons le faire aujourd'hui il est je
pense que non il n'a pas dit plus jamais
pas demain non plus ben voila mais pas
demain c'est pas ma came mais
aujourd'hui les français n'y sont pas
favorables
donc je pense la sagesse c'est ne pas
brandir des chiffons rouges je ne sais
quoi
il faut faire ce que nous sommes
capables de faire nous pouvons faire le
vote des étrangers nous le faisons si
nous ne sommes pas en mesure parce que
la droite bloque à la changer d'avis la
droite d'ailleurs
nicolas sarkozy dans vers l'avenir car
victor est d'accord on n'a pas de
majorité on ne fait pas le sur la
justice sur le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature excusez moi nous voulions
le réformer et nous devrions le faire
nous n'avons pas la majorité des trois
cinquièmes un non plus donc bah on va
pas leur combat pas le présenter on va
pas faire un congrès à versailles
emmener tous les parlementaires surtout
que si nous faisions un congrès à
versailles
vous nous diriez vous peut-être mais à
quoi ça sert combien ça coûte et
pourquoi vont-ils là bas pour être
battus il n'y a pas de majorité en
france pour le voir les autres anges et
je ne valais n'a pas évident qu'on
arrête de l'absence de majorité
et là j'ai les bras qui n'a pas évoqué
le congrès d'après deux volets facto
thèmes qu'on abandonne en cours de route
et qui ne figurera plus dans les
promesses électorales
si sa figure g et je pense qu'il a
raison de dire que nous ne sommes nous
ne sommes pas en mesure de nous mettre
en place que la population n'y est pas
forcément favorable
donc nous devrons réfléchir je pense que
nous allons fédéral et c'est la mort
d'une promesse sans couronne
je ne sais pas ce que ça c'est bien
merci les cils troisième partie des 93
maintenant avec cette question d'aider
guillaume quelle république justement
quelle république demain qui n'a pas
aujourd'hui à droite comme à gauche veut
des idées pour réformer la république
petit aperçu c'est toute l'architecturé
qui repensé lorsque l'on dit un
septennat unique pour le président de la
république c'est pour qu'il puisse avoir
cette année pleine et même constat
divorce autres politiques et citoyens
le même constat
lui pense que la solution se la réforme
institutionnelle je dis non
ce constat c'est quoi c'est le résultat
de la crise économique et social ces le
résultat aussi de la parole politique ou
y compris on lance des écrans de fumée
pour ne pas traiter les sujets je pense
qu'il faut poser un certain nombre de
questions qui n'est pas illégitime de
faire mieux fonctionner le parlement
c'est ce que le sénat a conduit
diminution pourquoi pas du nombre de
parlementaires je rappelle c'est
françois mitterrand qui les a augmentées
tout ceci sur des questions légitimes
elle ne signifie pas de boules verra
relâché sur vous la république soit
dédiée soit il faudrait tout changer
notamment changer d'abord nos
institutions
non mais c'est un tout c'est l'élection
présidentielle va arriver dans un an et
demi il faudra qu'un volet
institutionnel forcément tout va vite
dans ce pays nous parlions tout à
l'heure de macron des lois qu'il doit
qui doivent aller plus vite nous allons
dire un mot vraiment et je pense que
juno concitoyens veulent mieux
comprendre et il faudra clarifier un
certain nombre de choses aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui lorsqu'une loi est annoncée
en conseil des ministres mercredi matin
ils l aient voté un an et demi après
elle est mise en application deux ans ou
deux ans et demi après ce n'est plus
possible
donc là à l'ère des réseaux à l'ère des
réseaux sociaux à l'ère d'internet de
facebook de twitter et des chaînes
d'information en continu et de public
sénat
une bonne chose d'aller beaucoup plus
vite on laissait forcément une bonne
chose quand le pays le demande je prends
le temps la réflexion non mais attendez
je dis pas qu'il faut arrêter de
réfléchir je dis simplement que
aujourd'hui une loi pour transformer le
souhaitait prendre trop de temps
la loi macron devant passer beaucoup de
temps
s'il ya urgence alors il faut que aller
il faut aller plus vite mais c'est pas
uniquement ça la réforme des
institutions
c'est aussi mettre en avant la sirène
les solutions calendrier parlementaire
parce que ici par exemple au sénat
gérard larcher a déjà mises en oeuvre
une réforme elle est insuffisante et
vous qu'est ce que selon vous donc
et qu'est-ce que vous proposons mais la
réforme qui mis en place par gérard
larcher c'est pour le fonctionnement du
sénat
c'est pas pour l'accélération du anzhi
alors oui on gagne du temps vous allez
non mais nous avons voté pour réduire
les temps de parole indispensable mais
au fond les retards sont imputables au
gouvernement au parlement d'un concile
dernière tous les gouvernements de
france de droite comme de gauche
répondent trop de lois et on line et loi
fourre tout c'est peut-être parce qu'il
fallait les faire parce que cela n'avait
pas été fait avant
donc il faut que nous arrivions à mieux
prioriser les lois du gouvernement puis
moi je vais vous dire donc vous voulez
revenir finalement sur la réforme oui
c'est une erreur car le non l avantage
ni motif un nom c'est une et c'est une
erreur cette loi de 2008 c'était une
bonne chose et on était tous pour dire
il faut rééquilibrer au partant aralar
taj et le temps de le faire et le temps
du gouvernement et on s'aperçoit que ça
ne ce n'est pas bien que c'est donc
finalement le parlement ne sera plus
qu'une machine à examiner comment ils
mais le nom mais pareil là vos
caricatures et si je peux me permettre
entre 50 50 et puis 100% il ya une
différence avant nous étions à 80 ou 90%
de tant de gouvernements et 10 ou 15 %
de temps de du parlement ont peut-être
trouvé la solution mais nous allons en
discuter mais je pense qu'il faut
laisser plus de temps pour le
gouvernement de présenter ses textes de
loi et puis il faut aussi j'en appelle à
la sagesse du gouvernement il ne faut
pas que chaque ministre veuille donner
son nom à une loi et donc faire beaucoup
de lois il faut il faut les prioriser
nous parlions du droit de vote des
étrangers ou d'autres il ya des lois qui
sont utiles et des lois qu'ils sont un
peu moins et des lois qui sont
prioritaires d'autres qui le sont un peu
moins
occupons nous de celles qui sont
prioritaires c'est ça qui est important
quand vous parlez des parlements est ce
que vous êtes aussi d'accord il ya
beaucoup de propositions de droite comme
de gauche qui vont dans ce sens là en ce
moment sur la diminution du nombre de
parlementaires
oui mais ça c'est dans un ensemble je
suis très favorable à une diminution du
nombre de
deux parlementaires parce que nous
pourrions nous serions 250 au sénat où
230 pourrait fonctionner pareillement
est-ce qu'on est obligé d'avoir autant
de députés et autant de sénateurs dans
les gros département je n'en suis pas
sûr mais je crois que c'est un ensemble
c'est comme lorsque le président
bartolone avec monsieur winoc disent il
faut le septennat non renouvelable moi
je suis très étaient opposés à la
réforme de lunettes jospin qui était un
de mes maîtres en politique qui a été la
version du calendrier et le quel quidam
enfin nous y sommes maintenant là encore
pas faire des zigzags ou des essuie
glaces
maintenant si les pauses c'est pas
revenir en arrière c'est revenir en
avant si je peux me permettre c'est si
nous faisions le septennat non
renouvelable alors le président de la
république serait qu'il a 7 ans et qu'il
n'a pas à penser et vinça pendant cette
s'appelle la démocratie
aujourd'hui mes obligations mais
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle est
aujourd'hui c'est la perrine tarneaud
aujourd'hui c'est le cas à bild ben oui
si une dissolution
aujourd'hui depuis plus quinquennat est
en place il ya pas de dissolution s'il
devait avoir avoir une dissolution
beaucoup moins probable mais oui mais
lorsqu'on parle institutions et
constitution on ne parle pas de
probabilité on ne parle pas de chose
comme ça on parle d'institutions globale
du vision de ce que nous devons nous
voulons faire c'est ça je crois qu'il
qu'un pas qui est important donc on nous
en sommes à deux quinquennats maximum je
pense que c'est parfait peut-être
pourrions-nous avoir un septennat non
renouvelables pourquoi pas d'accord
elles sont des idées que vous allez
exposé bientôt donc oui moi je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent que le volet
institutionnel sera important pour la
présidentielle et le groupe socialiste
et républicain que j'ai l'honneur de
présider fera des propositions après les
régionales nous voulons les faire avant
mais là on est dans la période régional
grâce à la rentrée de janvier youtube
riel donc un rapport qui va s'ajouter
oui elle contribue pour appeler sa
contribution au débat
oui exactement puis celle du président
larcher qui est le présent marché fera
ici et puisque nicolas sarkozy françois
hollande et d'autres mettront dans leurs
programmes de de campagne électorale
présidentielle
on se souvient de la limitation du cumul
des mandats qui avait été refusée par
une majorité des pollueurs
il s'empare mois nicolas sarkozy a dit
qu'il reviendrait
sur cette réforme on l'écouterait
exactement
j'ai toujours considéré que c'est un
grand risque à faire courir à notre pays
que d'avoir des assemblées
parlementaires parfaitement hors sol
n'ayant aucun mandat local pour
maintenir les parlementaires dans la
réalité démocratique de notre pays
alors vous pensez comme lui non mais là
ils m'ont à ilbo la droite ne pourra pas
revenir
non mais c'est pas vrai ce qui d ce
n'est absolument pas vrai ce qu'il dit
c'est pas le mandat unique qui a été mis
dans la loi c'est la possibilité d'avoir
un mandat local n'est plus mandat mais
moi je considère j'ai été président de
conseil général pendant une dizaine
d'années et je considère que je vis
beaucoup mieux maintenant
en me consacrant pleinement à la vie
parlementaire et je pense aujourd'hui
qu'il est incompatible d'être député
sénateur ou maire d'une grande ville ou
président de conseil général ou présente
conseil régional je les trouve
l'alimenter bien sûr je oui mais les
choses évoluent à vous dites ça vous
aimez vous avez été vous allez vous
aussi vous avez été battu
non je me suis par principe vous n'êtes
pas sur la gauche mais je me suis pas
représenté aux élections mais peu
importe
j'ai voté cette loi limitant le cumul
des mandats parce que ça faisait partie
des 60 propositions de françois hollande
dans la présidentielle
et personne n'y reviens dessus nouvelle
astra minoritaire dans votre nom
nicolas sartini colas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy dit c'est ce qu'on appelle un
peu le populisme c'est pas une attaque
mais dit à son auditoire que l'auditoire
veut entendre
donc il va voir les parlementaires et
leur dû mais vous pourrez continuer à
cumuler mais qu'est ce que c'est cette
histoire c'est nicolas sarkozy qui va
décider de nom ce sont les électeurs qui
décident si on cumule notion ne cumule
pas c'est pas le parti de le président
du parti les républicains moi je pense
que dans l'aération l'oxygénation de la
démocratie politique
le cumul des mandats c'est fini mais ce
qu'est la vraie question c'est pas aussi
le cumul la limitation du cumul
évidemment mais évidemment favoriser le
renouvellement évidemment l'atlas moi je
pense qu'on ne pourra pas partir
on ne devrait pas pouvoir on ne devrait
pas pouvoir exercer plus de trois fois
un mandat électoral que soit le mandat
de maire de départemental régional ou
aux parlementaires je pense ça serait
bien ça permettrait de 1,2 renouvelé
mais là encore c'est compliqué de mettre
en place parce que l'électeur décide de
ce qu'il veut décider oui s'il veut
réussir quelques 90 ans donc c'est
pourquoi faut le mettre dans la loi vous
le dites ça va être compliqué à mettre
en place c'est vrai que ces réformes
institutionnelles et a toujours beaucoup
de propositions pendant les campagnes
président jamais rien parce qu'il faut
une majorité des trois cinquièmes à
moins de questionner le peuple donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut que la gauche à la
droite mettent d'accord c'est sûr il ya
un peu de corporatisme auditionné
parfois mais il peut y avoir du
corporatisme et vous savez les gens les
gens ils sont pour la limitation du
cumul des mandats mais ils votent pour
le le maire qu'ils connaissent pas ce
qui les députés souvent c'est comme cela
que ce genre de sujets il y aurait un
référendum après l'élection
présidentielle en 2017
moi je serais assez favorable donc il
faudra passer par un référendum serait
une grande réforme - est choquant pour
moi les choses sont liées chaussures et
que le programme de françois hollande je
n'en sais rien
non ah bon j'aimerais la plupart c'est
elle qui était l'engagement je prends à
48 dans le programme de françois
hollande en 2012 n'a jamais vu le jour
non plus parce que nous n'avons pas la
majorité pour le faire
le sénat est une majorité de droite
conservatrice respectable mais qui
bloque toute possibilité d'évolution des
uns de nos institutions
et comme il faut la majorité de trois
cinquièmes ce n'est pas possible
et alors le sénat justement n'en a pas
encore parlé dans mon équilibre
institutionnel certains comme claude
bartelone voudrait bien voir l' autre
assemblée disparaître ou fusionner avec
le conseil économique et social vous
non moi je suivrai une proposition le
groupe socialiste et républicain fera
une proposition d' un bicamérisme
moderniser rénové et plus efficace je
pense que nous avons besoin de deux
champs savez si mes souvenirs sont bons
il ya deux pays au monde où n'y a pas de
senna c'est la corée du nord est et cuba
vous essayer de calmer les ardeurs de
votre famille claude bartolone
débâcle bartolone a rendu un rapport à
l'excellent winoc voilà vous êtes
maintenant autant fâché qu'avec lui que
que l'actuel président du salon
changement je ne suis pas fier mais
claude bartolone et est un grand ami à
moi alors je vais j'espère le meilleur
je souhaite le meilleur pour le 13
décembre 28 listes sur les 330 de qui
ont été dépouillés pour les élections
régionales sont menées par une femme la
parité
d'accord mais elle est encore loin elle
s'arrête notamment à la porte des
exécutifs locaux est ce que sur ce point
là aussi il faut aller plus loin on peut
pas aller plus loin c'est impossible
nous à la gauche a mis la parité dans
toutes les élections c'est la gauche qui
a fait tout le temps les avancées sur la
parité
partout dans les entreprises et au
niveau politique et électoral s'arrête
là où sauf que on ne peut pas imposer
on ne peut pas imposer par la loi le
fait de dire la tête de liste doit être
de tel sexe ce n'est pas possible c'est
interdit je le regrette
il pourrait avoir beaucoup plus mais
c'est comme ça nous fait un hack'n 28
mai encore oui c'est vrai que l'on va
compter c'est ce que nous avons fait non
mais faut pas en rire parce que rien n'a
avancé
aux élections municipales en 2014 pour
la première fois les listes étaient
paritaire à partir de 1000 habitants
et j'espère que la prochaine fois sera
tout les pour les élections
départementales dans tous les
départements de france la parité est
totale mais votre propre parti est
effectif
on n'a pas le droit de la tête de lit
non mais vous pourriez alors vous savez
bien sûr non mais alors là je suis je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous sans
passer par une loi
une culpabilité comportementale vous
et à propos des nouvelles régions qui
verront le jour le 1er janvier prochain
écouter ce que dit le président
des gens qui sauf lagarde est ce qu'il
veut et ce qu'il envisage de retoucher
cette carte de france
écoutez le ci ont rechange et entre
guillemets cette carte qui est ni fait
ni à faire qui a été fait pour des
raisons électoralistes
quand on l'est par exemple la loire
atlantique avec c'est essentiellement
pour faire plaisir à monsieur le drian
quand on met aquitaine poitou charentes
et limousin excusez moi pour définir
l'interrégional rêve des régionales ça
va être un peu compliqué c'est certain
c'est une carte des copains c'est une
carte des copains qui a été concocté
dans un petit coin de bureau à l'elysée
par monsieur hollande
il n'en reste pas moins que leur bouger
cette carte sert perde du temps alors
partie sociale et sa place et ses petits
copains mais enfin mais là encore
qu'elle exerce l exagération c'est bien
mal connaître la bretagne que de
maintenance en bretagne qu'est ce que ça
veut dire sur un coin de table mais où
elles se font les lois au gouvernement
mais non pas par les français notamment
dans certaines régions dites mauvaises
moselle oui mais aujourd'hui aux
situations les citoyens pardon appui
vraiment c'est assez drôle tarnos et que
chaque fois qu'il est une grande réforme
on dit faut pas la faire nous sommes
dans un pays qui est sclérosé c'est pour
ça que nous ayons de tout à l'heure il
faut avancer et pédaler et avancer
contre vents et marées contre l'avis de
la droite on risque d'en haut risque de
la défaite c'est pas la fusion des
régions qui nous faire perdre guaino
nous nous pensons ça fait 30 ans que il
a été dit par tout le monde il faut
fusionner les régions phares des grandes
régions
la droite l'a annoncé dix fois ne l'a
jamais fait françois hollande a annoncé
une fois il l'a fait voilà le
volontarisme politique perrine la
dernière question des missions on
assiste en ce moment à l'émergence de
beaucoup de mouvement
citoyen est ce que c'est le prémice
finalement peut-être de la fin les
partis politiques qui déçoivent parfois
les citoyens les partis politiques
déçoivent beaucoup les citoyens moi
qu'un discute chez moi dans la drôme à
bourg de péage dans mon département dans
ma ville
les gens me regardent ils me disent mais
toi on t'aime bien vous aime bien vous
n'êtes pas comme les autres enfin les
partis c'est fini puisqu'ils disent les
gens la politique c'est pourri c'est
tous les mêmes
la droite et de la gauche et les mêmes
et parfois ça les parties soient les
amène à moudre je parle des partis est
parti sur les ramène à voter pour pour
pour l'extrême droite
qu'est-ce qu'il arrive on prête la
volontaire et jean christophe cambadélis
de lancer un grand mouvement citoyen il
faut dépasser les parts début 2016 vous
confirmez ou y regarder tous les partis
politiques aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté alors ce sera quoi de
l'extrême-droite
nous voulons faire une grande fédération
avec des socialistes des écologistes les
radicaux
je pense qu'il faut dépasser le parti
socialiste nous ne sommes plus à l'ère
des partis mais à l'ère des idées donc
mourir pour mieux renaître
oui on peut se le phénix c'est ça manuel
valls avait dit de partir dans le
service peut mourir
et oui mais les faire mourir brutalement
il s'agit
il s'agit pas de mourir il s'agit de
créer autre chose oui de se dépasser
aujourd'hui étant de la partie facile
mais alors là c'est pareil regarder
votre ambivalence vous me dites les
partis politiques de sérieux nous
confiance je vous dis que nous le
confirmait les partis politiques sont
malade tousse tousse et qu' il faut
aller plus loin et que la gauche les
socialistes veulent être exemplaire en
créant un mouvement une grande maison
une alliance ouverte une fédération
ouverte dans laquelle il y aura de la
gauche plurielle
non pas du tout je vais beaucoup plus
loin vous parlez des citoyens dans
lequel il y aura les partis politiques
je l'espère le prg ni d eux les
socialistes mais des citoyens qui ne
veulent pas adhérer à un parti politique
mais qui veulent adhérer sur des idées
sur une idée sont une orientée suivre
envers la forme ouvrir les portes et les
fenêtres début 2016 avec donc la rue de
solférino qui va ouvrir ses portes et
ses fenêtres on a et ayant de voir ça
merci beaucoup d'énergie à vous merci
perrine merci bonsoir à tout ça très
vite